we are excited to announce the launch of
our official anime app or website at
anime port calm we're kicking things off
with the Opie AAF collection created by
pro manga artist Puzo MIDI featuring
such overpowered designed as signs all
gone
the world is yours harem King Deku gotta
smash them all the sin of pride Eskin or
praise the Sun and the Beast Titan in
full beast mode visit enemy for calm or
click the link in the description thank
you
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be explaining every single type of
Titan in the attack on Titan series
after Rodri says gigantic 120 meter
Titan form was introduced in season 3 of
the anime there has been a flood of
comments on our videos asking us what
type of Titan this is and also what
differentiates all the various types of
Titans from each other and so for your
convenience in this video we'll be
clarifying all the different types and
distinctions between the Titans
including of course rod Reese's massive
Titan that somehow grew to be two times
as big as the colossal Titan if you can
believe that if you enjoy the attack on
Titan videos on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe and
colossal smash that notification bell
and if you have any requests for future
video stuff you want us to cover in the
future be sure to follow us on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar and let us
know this video will include some manga
spoilers about the true nature of the
Titans and the various types of Titans
please be advised and proceed with
caution starting things off with pure
Titans normally between three metres and
15 meters in height pure Titans are also
known as mindless Titans because of
their behavior
pure Titans are the most common type of
Titan and they will mindlessly attack
the nearest human in an attempt to
devour them we know that Titans don't
need to eat humans to survive
Titans appear to use some form of
photosynthesis in order to convert
sunlight into energy and the only time
that we see Titans run out of energy is
when they are deprived of sunlight for a
long period of time in line with the
fact that Titans don't need to eat to
survive they do not have a working
digestive tract once their stomach fills
with human flesh that they consumed
Titan simply regurgitate the contents
and look for more humans to consume it
is believed that the reason that Titans
eat humans is the fact that they are
hoping to turn back into humans
themselves by consuming a human who is a
Titan shifter as was of course the case
with Amir from the
fourth training core she turned back
into a human after 60 years of roaming
around as a mindless Titan after
consuming Marcel who was the possessor
of the JA titan power at the time as a
result Emir turned back into a human and
became the possessor of the jaw Titan
and a Titan shifter herself but more
about Titan shifters later all people
who belong to the ethnic group known as
the subjects of Amir or
LD ins can be turned into mindless
Titans if they are injected with Titan
spinal fluid members of other ethnic
groups are not affected like all other
Titans pure Titans have the ability to
quickly regenerate their bodies and heal
even the most serious wounds the only
way to kill them is to cut the nape of
the neck thereby destroying the central
nervous system of the Titan next up are
the wall Titans the wall Titans are
massive Titans who resemble the colossal
Titan in both size and appearance these
Titans have the ability to harden their
bodies and they are currently dispersed
throughout the three walls and they're
effectively making up the inner core of
the walls these wall Titans are said to
have been created by King Karl fritz as
a way to keep Outsiders from interfering
into the affairs of the isolated walled
off kingdom according to legend Karl
fritz used the power of the founding
Titan to create tens of millions of
these wall Titans and he then used them
to build the walls due to the fact that
these Titans are currently hidden away
from sunlight they are dormant and
inactive but if the walls are destroyed
and sunlight shines on the Titans they
could snap to life and potentially level
the entire earth I mean just imagine
millions of colossal Titans roaming
around destroying everything before them
however it is important to know that
some sources like recall yeah Nikita's
book about the science of attack on
Titans suggests that for all three walls
to be filled with colossal Titans less
than a million Titans would be needed
not tens of millions to be honest less
than a million is a much more realistic
number as
specially if we considered that unless
the founding Titan has another way to
make Titans that we still don't know
about each of these tens of millions of
all Titans would have to have been a
human being before becoming a Titan the
idea that Carl fritz
sacrificed tens of millions of people to
create the walls is less likely than the
idea that he used less than 1 million
personally I tend to believe that if
tens of millions of aliens were
available to be turned into wall Titans
then it is hard to imagine how the
enemies of the audience were able to
overwhelm them in the first place I mean
a nation of tens of millions of
potential fighters would not be easy to
subjugate in the way that the aliens
were apparently subjugated following the
great titan war but those are just some
of my observations we don't have full
information about the history of attack
on Titan at least not yet next up we
have the abnormal Titans abnormal Titans
are distinguished from pure Titans by
their abnormal behavior unlike mindless
Titans abnormals often demonstrate some
form of intelligence and several
abnormal Titans have even demonstrated
the ability to speak and interact with
other humans while pure Titans simply go
after the first human they see abnormal
Titans will often ignore the first
humans they see and they will instead
attack key strategic locations or places
that have the largest concentration of
humans abnormal Titans also demonstrate
unpredictable abilities that most pure
Titans do not such as running after a
target instead of simply walking or even
jumping over obstacles in order to reach
their target some examples of abnormal
Titans include the talking Titan who
spoke to Ilse Langner during the 34th
expedition the Titan that used to be
Connie's mother and of course the
infamous smiling Titan now let's talk a
bit about Rod Reese's 120 meter Titan
the ginormous Titan that is created when
Rod rescan zooms the Titan serum is
usually classified as just another
abnormal Titan but there are some hints
that rod rhesus Titan could be unique
and we have gotten enough questions
about this Titan in particular to
justify giving it some special attention
the rod reese titan is the biggest titan
that we have ever seen and at 120 meters
in height he is
twice the size of the colossal Titan
aside from being unnaturally large Rodri
says Titan constantly generates steam so
hard that it's set nearby trees and
shrubbery on fire as the Titan moved
because of its immense size and
disproportionate body dimensions the rod
reese titan was unable to walk upright
and so he resorted to crawling on all
fours in order to move but his rod resis
tightened just another abnormal who
happened to grow unusually large by
coincidence or is there more to this
titan this tightens behavior was in line
with abnormal tightens the rod reese
titan ignored the humans closest to him
and headed straight for or wood district
a population center with a large number
of humans concentrated in a relatively
small area but there are a few hints
that suggest that rod rhesus Titan
transformation was unique in some way
for one thing throughout his life
rod Reiss was adamant about the fact
that he cannot become a Titan he didn't
say that he didn't want to he implied
that he couldn't as if he knew that
something would go horribly wrong if he
did now maybe rod Reiss was just scared
and that's the only reason why he
wouldn't become a Titan and why he kept
pressuring other members of his family
to inherit the founding titan power but
there is also the matter of Rod Reese's
death we know that in the case of pure
and abnormal Titans the nape of the
Titans neck contains only the spine of
the human who had turned into that
particular Titan the rest of the body
disintegrates or blends with the Titan
flesh and only the spine remains but
once this spine is severed the Titan
dies however if we look back to the
scene in which historia deals the final
blow to Rod rhesus Titan we see that rod
rhesus entire body appears to be still
intact inside the Titan as historians
through the nape of the gigantic Titans
neck we appear to see rod Reese in the
flesh and not just his spine as far as
we know right now the only type of Titan
inside of which the human body stays
intact and doesn't disintegrate is a
Titan shifter
so if Rod Reese's body remained whole
inside the Titans nape instead of
disintegrating this would suggest that
Rod Reese's Titan was
not just a regular abnormal tighten but
maybe some type of quasi shifter part
shifter part abnormal or something along
those lines there is also another odd
discrepancy with the rod reese titan in
the moment that she kills him historia
appears to see some of Rod Reese's
memories and because of this she appears
to understand some of Rods true feelings
towards her and his family now this is
not something that we see when a pure
Titan or an abnormal tight are killed
so this brief incidents stuck out in my
mind as well it could be that Rod
Reese's strange transformation is a
result of the fact that he did not
inject himself with the titan serum
properly and simply licked it off the
ground or it could be the result of the
fact that rod Reese has royal blood or
some combination of the two
at any rate although rod Reese's 120
meter Titan is officially classified as
an abnormal there are some
inconsistencies there some features that
this Titan exhibits that don't quite fit
our definition of an abnormal Titan
since we don't know for sure I want to
ask you guys to give me your thoughts
down in the comments do you think that
Rod Reese's Titan is just an abnormal
Titan that happened to grow unusually
big or do you think that this Titan was
some sort of strange mix between an
abnormal and a Titan shifter let me know
down below I'd love to get a good
discussion going and finally the final
type of Titan within the attack on Titan
series the Titan shifter
according to legend nearly 2,000 years
ago a woman known as Emir Fritz somehow
awoke to the power of the Titans
although the exact way that she attained
her power is still a mystery she is
considered to have been the first Titan
and the ancestors of all the subjects of
Emir also known as LD ins Emir Fritz
died 13 years after she first awakened
to her Titan power and after her death
her soul was split into nine different
titan powers that then passed on to nine
different successors the nine Titan
shifters that were created include the
founding titan the attack titan the
female titan the jaw titan the armored
Titan the colossal or Colossus Titan the
cart
tighten the
beasts tighten and the warhammer tighten
each tighten shifter has its own unique
powers and abilities and the powers of a
titan shifter can be fully unlocked only
if the holder of this power has royal
blood if you want to learn more about
all nine Titan shifters and their
specific powers I will link a video down
below and at the end of this video so
you can check out all of that
information because there is a lot of it
also if you want to see my theory for
how a mere Fritz attained the Titan
power in the first place and what the
true origin of the Titans is I will link
my video on that particular topic in the
description as well without getting into
all of the specifics because we've
already covered them in a previous video
the nine Titan shifters have their own
unique powers and abilities unlike other
Titans Titans are intelligent and the
power of a Titan shifter is passed on
from one LD n to another when the LD n
in pure Titan form consumes the spinal
fluid of the original Titan shifter the
pure Titan will then turn back into a
human but the human will now have the
ability to transform back into a tight
shifter at will
due to the curse of Amir who died 13
years after awakening to her Titan power
every person who becomes a Titan shifter
will inevitably die thirteen years after
first gaining the power if the power is
not passed on to someone else before
then the power will be inherited by the
next LD and baby that is born into the
world following the death of the shifter
on top of that the memory is a very
tight shifter continue to live on in the
new user although at least in the case
of the founding Titan these memories are
clearer for users who have royal blood
while regular LD ends who inherit the
Titan power don't have full access to
these memories theoretically a founding
Titan user with royal blood would have
access to the memories of previous
shifters all the way back to Emir Fritz
herself the final important thing to
consider about the Titan shifter powers
is that one person can consume more than
one Titan power at once
for example even anime only Watchers
know that Eren possesses both the attack
Titan and the founding Titan power and
the big question is what would happen if
one person came to possess all nine
powers at once would that person attain
some sort of extraordinary ability that
rivals Ahmir Fritz herself would that
person be able to
do things that seem impossible to us
right now things that would completely
change the world of attack on Titan as
we know it this is a big question that
I've been wondering about myself is
Aaron going to end up uniting all nine
Titan powers within himself and if he
does it how will that change him what
would that mean for the story give me
your thoughts down below this is another
topic an attack on Titan that I'm
extremely interested in so I really want
to get a great conversation going and
that is it all the known types of Titans
in attack on Titan explained if you
enjoyed this type of video and you want
to see more you can leave a like to let
me know if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and colossal
smash that notification bell feel free
to hit us up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime up or for requests for future
videos as always thank you all so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you